I'm telling you right now I don't say 80
of the stuff that I know the objective
is to build trust there's plenty of
stars who will remain nameless every
Stephen amen let me talk to you man this
is [__] is happening like for example
you can sit up there I'm famous stay off
the weed and all of this stuff right I'm
not talking about just anybody I got
family members friends people smoke some
weed I'm talking about the cats that has
cost them money so if I'm sitting there
and I'll bring up something like that
right and then you high as [__] you walk
by the scorers table I could smell you
wobble it around but let me tell you
something you can see these guys and
they wobbling they can't understand
plays you'll see something like that
right I'll write a story now this is how
I handle it I'm not gonna die in my
mouth I'll be like this this brother
shot three for 23 last night he made
this mistake this mistake doesn't I
don't know what the hell he was doing
last night but right because that's me
letting you know I know what the [__] he
was doing last night